no i i we talked about it during the
break but i mean the donovan side of it
i think shaq was looking for a response
from donovan right
that that he didn't get but shot come
from a different school
and his the way that he comes out did i
do that to you though that's the way you
did it to me but
i you were my vet and i didn't have
another i have a choice and i was just
testing this temperature that's all but
everybody oh he's a no man listen ain't
nothing personal with me
trust me never they're never personal
with it so what about rudy though
oh that sounds personal to me no i'm
saying cause let's this is what happened
to me when i was a youngster
i was always overshadowed by the guards
kenny anderson
jimmy jackson whatever and i was putting
up big numbers but i was six seven eight
or nine ten so what up
so when i thought about doing something
else my father bought me an article one
day i said hey man
keep going john concake who was okay but
he made 15
for three five minutes so i'm saying to
all the little big guys
that don't have the followings like like
mikey and all those guys just keep doing
what you do and then
if you can come and average this this is
the type of numbers you can get and
everybody oh you hate
bro get your money i'm get all your
money take everything
i'm glad i'm happy for you but that's
what i was trying to say and see that's
that's why i don't like talking to
earthlings because y'all don't
understand my language earthlings
oh yeah yeah y'all are earthlings oh
he's hating i'm not hating i want the
man to get but i'm saying
to all the big guys out there who can't
really jump high
but you know can play defense you know
you're a great role player you're not
the star on the team
if you can come in and play like this
consistently play this this is possibly
what you can get
yeah that's all i was saying so don't
you think d wade
that part of it also is in getting a
reaction out of your teammates or
getting a reaction as somebody is also
knowing
what what motivates them mm-hmm and how
how they're motivated and to me donovan
mitchell is not going to be a guy that's
going to get on
and and yell and scream he's going to
back it up with the way that he's
playing in his actions i want
okay that's great but i think a lot of
people were looking at colbert
and donovan mitchell in a certain way
because they didn't come back at shaq
and i think a lot of people interpreted
that as not being tough listen i want
them to come back please
they have respect but you got to
understand who you are in this game
guys are not going to come back at you
because they haven't accomplished
what you've accomplished that's why it's
not about respect i know what i'm doing
when i'm trying to get my guys to play
at a certain level the way they're
playing right now you're welcome
well see adam so my whole life i want to
expect to explain it
sometimes
numbers you say okay the a guy tonight
who had three blocks and nine points and
seven rebounds you look at that and you
say yeah that guy is not worth 200
million right that's how you look at it
but also you got to also understand that
sometime as a player you got to take
advantage of the rules
whether it's taking advantage of the
foul rules or just taking advantage of
the situation you put in rudy was put in
a situation where he became a super max
player when he became defensive player
of the year
that means that super max that means
that he is eligible to get the super max
which is 230 million dollars
he didn't even take 230 million he was
actually being nice
and allow utah to have a little extra
money in the pot to go out and build
this
i'm talking about all the little kids
all the big guys that you know don't
have what you had don't have what lebron
had
if you come in and play a certain way
you can get this so john koncak made me
who i am today because i was thinking
about doing something else
but i want to put this in perspective
the jazz have won 12 of their last 13.
whether or not you want to give credit
to shaq for that
no we're not giving i'm not giving
credit for that i don't want credit but
i know but
but i know when i say certain thing and
players get mad i know what type of good
they are i'll also know what type of guy
donovan mitchell is so you're welcome
next tuesday welcome cause they try to
shut me up please shut me up
next tuesday the jazz are on tnt oh we
can get them to do an interview
and i hope that if they win